digamos que tenemos los ejes coordinados
aquí tenemos el eje de las leyes aquí
tenemos el eje de las equis aunque ya
estamos en r2 y digamos que tenemos
cuatro puntos
ok empezamos por el punto cero cero
el punto 00 lo podemos denotar de esta
forma y como siempre es mucho más fácil
ponerle nombres a todas las cosas así es
que a este punto le voy a empezar a
llamar a muy bien ahora digamos que
tenemos otro punto que está especificado
por las coordenadas que a 10 te parece
bien este punto entonces lo que tenemos
que hacer es fijarnos en el eje de las
equis buscar a cada uno digamos que está
por acá que 1 y entonces nuestro punto
es justo este puntito ok el vector que a
cero es este vector y este es el punto
que determine al cual le vamos a empezar
a llamar b digamos que también tenemos
otro punto porque se empieza a notar que
quiero hacer un rectángulo verdad bueno
y este vector
que termina este punto es el vector
k1 k2
ok así es que por acá está el escalar
cada dos que estés cada uno es cada dos
y finalmente vamos a escoger el último
punto y ese va a ser este puntito por
aquí ok y este vector no es otra cosa
que el vector 0 k 2 ok a este punto le
vamos a llamar el punto
y en este punto le vamos a llamar el
punto se habrá algo que nos interesa de
estos cuatro puntos es el rectángulo que
forman estos cuatro puntos a la hora de
unirlos forman este rectángulo déjamelo
abrevió y en lugar de poner rectángulo
le pongo simplemente rec
es el rectángulo
del rey
formado
al conectar al conectar los puntos los
puntos
abc y the monkey
d
aunque yo sea justo este rectángulo
este es el rectángulo rec y bueno ya que
tenemos un rectángulo nos podemos
preguntar cuál es el área contenida
dentro de este rectángulo cierto a ver
cuál es el
a área
del rectángulo
néctar
pues si te fijas bien este es un
rectángulo común y corriente y el área
contenida dentro de cualquier rectángulo
y simplemente va a ser por altura la
base es esta longitud de aquí y esta
longitud es simplemente que a 1 entonces
el área del rectángulo es
por la altura pero la altura es la
longitud de este otro vector y esta es
simplemente k 2 entonces aquí tenemos
que el área contenida en el rectángulo
es k 1 por k 2 bueno hasta este punto no
te he enseñado nada del otro mundo pero
si vamos a ver cosas interesantes en
este vídeo vamos a transformar a este
rectángulo aunque hoy vamos a usar la
transformación t
te va a ser una transformación de r2 en
r2 que la podemos escribir como si
aplicamos ate en un vector x eso es
igual a tomar la matriz ha de ser de
y multiplicarla por el vector x entonces
lo que nos interesa es ver como esta
transformación transforma a este
rectángulo y vimos hace muchos vídeos
que para encontrar la imagen de un
rectángulo bajo una transformación de
esta forma lo único que necesitábamos
era saber a dónde van a dar cada una de
las esquinas ok entonces lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es encontrar cuál es
la imagen bajo t de estos cuatro puntos
entonces empecemos por ver cuál es t d
esto es simplemente de de ser
entonces ponemos aquí en nuestro vector
0 0 y nos queda 0 x + 0 por ver eso está
en la primera entrada y eso es
simplemente un 0 y para obtener la
segunda entrada del vector tenemos que
multiplicar 0 por c + 0 por d y eso es
simplemente un 0 aunque ya ahora vamos
con la transformación aplicada al punto
b o sea la transformación en k 1 0
ok
cada uno por a +0 por be o sea a por
cada uno y en la segunda entrada nos
queda cada uno por c + 0 por d o sea que
a 1 x 6
sé por cada uno
y listo ahora veamos que aplicado al
punto c
transformando a k1 k2
y eso es igual
tenemos aquí cada uno por a
cada uno por a más k 2 x b
cada 2 por b
y en la segunda entrada tenemos cada uno
por ser
uno por ser más k 2 por d
2 por d finalmente tenemos que evaluar
la transformación en el punto b
o sea tenemos que sacar la
transformación de 0 a 2
0 2
0 x 0 +2 por b
cada 2 por b y en la segunda entrada nos
queda 0 x 0 mascados por de jose a
cada dos por d entonces vamos a volver a
dibujar nuestros x coordenadas
este es el eje vertical y este es el eje
horizontal y ahora dibujemos en estos
nuevos ejes la imagen de nuestro
rectángulo reik bajo la transformación
de ok entonces como vimos hace muchos
vídeos lo que tenemos que hacer es
dibujar las imágenes de nuestros
puntitos bajo la transformación t y
después unir esos puntos gay porque esta
es una transformación lineal entonces te
vea o sea te dé 0 0 se va al 0 0
así es que aquí tenemos un puntito que
éste d
pero cero
luego vamos a dibujar tv que es acá uno
y después seca uno ok entonces pues no
sabemos quiénes son hacen ivd pero
digamos que al graficar este vector se
ve de esta forma ok entonces este
puntito por acá tiene que ser a cada uno
este puntito por acá tiene que ser
cada uno
aunque
este es el otro punto de la imagen de
nuestro rectángulo bien entonces tenemos
que dibujar cuál es la imagen bajo la
transformación de dc pero saben que iba
a ser muchísimo más fácil si dibujamos
primero en este punto ok entonces
estamos dibujando la imagen de este
puntito que resulta ser k2b y k2 de
entonces digamos que lo grafica mos y
que queda más o menos por acá ok
este punto de aquí
k 2 b y este punto de aquí
cada dos de ok este puntito de aquí es
de de y este puntito de aquí este de de
entonces nada más nos falta que desee
ahora te desea es cada uno a más cada 2
b
aquí tenemos cada uno a más k 2 b
entonces tenemos que tomar esta longitud
y sumarse la a esta longitud así es que
nos va a quedar más o menos por qué
entonces ustedes se va a estar en algún
punto en esta recta y por otro lado
tenemos que la segunda coordenada de ted
s es cada uno se masca 2 d
aunque hay aquí tenemos cada uno se y
aquí tenemos acá 2 d
entonces otra vez tenemos que tomar esta
longitud y sumarse la a esta longitud
entonces nos va a quedar más o menos por
aquí este puntito es cdc entonces como
decíamos la imagen de este rectángulo
bajo la transformación te la podemos
obtener simplemente uniendo estos puntos
que son las imágenes de los vértices de
este rectángulo entonces este lado del
rectángulo cuando le aplicamos la
transformación t se transforma en este
lado del rectángulo imagen y lo mismo
pasa con este lado del rectángulo aunque
cuando le aplicamos la transformación t
se transforma en este lado ya nada más
nos falta este lado del rectángulo que
se transforma en este lado del
rectángulo imagen y finalmente el último
lado del rectángulo este lado de aquí
se transforma en este lado de aquí
entonces este rumbo de aquí es la imagen
bajo la transformación de este
rectángulo que este rombo
la imagen del rectángulo rec bajo la
transformación
qué imagen
del rectángulo rec
bajo la transformación de y algo que nos
podemos preguntar ahora es cuál es el
área de este rumbo
entonces ahorita lo que queremos es
averiguar cuál es el área
de té de rey
ok
y para sacar el área de este rombo
podemos acordarnos del vídeo pasado para
empezar este rombo es un paralelogramo
generado por estos dos vectores entonces
pues podemos poner una matriz
matriz a cada uno
cada uno de cada dos y de cada dos
estuve aquí los saque de este vector ok
tomamos los dos vectores que generan a
este paralelogramo o sea este vector que
es el vector a caa1 a ca 1 c k 1 se k 1
entonces este vector columna de esta
matriz es nada más y nada menos que te
aplicado a b y este otro vector columna
de aquí lo sacamos del otro vector que
general paralelogramo o sea de t
aplicado a de gei t aplicado de es k 2 b
y su otra coordenada es k 2 por d y aquí
también pusimos deportados entonces esta
es una matriz cuyos vectores columna
estos dos vectores son sus vectores
columna generan a un paralelogramo y lo
que vimos en el vídeo pasado es que el
valor absoluto del determinante de esta
matriz es exactamente igual al área
de este paralelogramo que a su vez es la
imagen del rectángulo que teníamos en un
inicio aquí pero tenemos que escribirlo
todo con calma vamos a empezar por
llamarle a esta matriz la matriz
y de imagen y entonces lo que sabemos a
partir de lo que vimos en el vídeo
pasado es que el valor absoluto del
determinante de la matriz y osea el
valor absoluto del determinante de esta
matriz esto es igual al área del
paralelogramo generado por los vectores
columna de la matriz i y estos vectores
columnas son este vector y este vector
que generan a este paralelogramo que es
la imagen bajo t de el rectángulo que
teníamos originalmente ok entonces el
determinante de la matriz y es igual al
área
al área de la imagen bajo la
transformación del rectángulo rec
ok muy bien entonces vamos a empezar por
calcular este determinante que como es
una matriz de 2 x 2 es muy fácil de
calcular
simplemente acá uno por de cada dos a
cada uno
x
de que dos menos becados por seca uno de
cada dos por cero
cada uno pero le tenemos que poner valor
absoluto entonces el determinante de un
valor absoluto es igual a esto de aquí
y aquí lo que podemos hacer es
factorizar el k1 y k2 de estos dos
términos y entonces nos queda
que uno por cada dos por ab - b c
que ella empieza a sonar conocido esto
por aquí bueno pues resulta que esto de
aquí es el determinante de la matriz que
define a la transformación t aunque sea
esta matriz de aquí le llamamos la
matriz a entonces esto de aquí es el
determinante de la matriz a y entonces
el área de la imagen de nuestro
rectángulo bajo la transformación t es
igual en cada uno por cada 2 por el
valor absoluto del determinante de la
matriz a recordemos que la matriz a es
la que define a la transformación t y
esto es algo súper interesante súper
bonito
si tenemos un conjunto que tiene cierta
área en este caso el conjunto es un
rectángulo y el área es cada uno por
cada 2
igual a cada uno porque a 2
y tenemos una transformación lineal que
al ser lineal se puede escribir como
la multiplicación de una matriz que en
este caso va a ser la matriz
multiplicando al vector en el cual
estamos evaluando a la transformación
entonces el área de la imagen de nuestro
conjunto bajo la transformación t o sea
el área dt del conjunto va a ser igual
al área original por el determinante de
la matriz que define a la transformación
t ok tenemos aquí nuestro conjunto que
tiene un área de tamaño que a 1 por cada
2 si nos fijamos en la imagen bajo la
transformación t de ese conjunto el área
de ese conjunto va a ser igual al área
que teníamos antes por el determinante
de la matriz a que define a la
transformación t y listo eso está
precioso no
y es una idea muy bonita o sea el
determinante de la matriz que define a
la transformación hacia el determinante
de a es el factor de escala entre el
área del rectángulo original y el área
de la imagen y eso no lo voy a demostrar
con todo cuidado pero podemos
visualizarlo no sea digamos por aquí
tenemos nuestro dominio r2 y digamos que
tenemos una región un conjunto vamos a
poner un conjunto que sea familiar para
todos pongamos por ejemplo una elipse y
a este elipse como siempre es bueno
poner los nombres a las costas vamos a
decir que es de elipse
y esta elipse pues tiene cierta área
y digamos que el área
el área de nuestra elipse es simplemente
a digamos también que tenemos una
transformación una transformación t que
va de los reales en la segunda dimensión
o sea de todos
r2 otra vez y que además es una
transformación lineal que se puede
escribir como
de x igual a una matriz de multiplicada
por el vector en el que estamos
evaluando a la transformación aunque
entonces digamos que este elipse cuando
le aplicamos la transformación te va a
dar a otro conjunto digamos esta región
ok entonces esto de aquí este d
y estamos diciendo que cada uno de los
puntitos de la elipse o sea del contorno
de esta región va a dar a algún puntito
de este contorno gay y que cualquier
puntito de este contorno es la imagen de
algún puntito por acá si no no formaría
parte de la imagen tv bueno esto no lo
vamos a demostrar pero resulta que cada
puntito adentro de la elipse termina
dentro de la elipse tve y que además
cada puntito adentro de tve o sea todos
estos puntos de aquí
cada uno de los puntos de aquí adentro
son la imagen de algún puntito adentro
de la elipse
ok todo este conjunto va a dar bajo la
transformación t a este conjunto de aquí
no vamos a demostrar esto solo lo vamos
a visualizar el chiste es que si sacamos
el área de esta región su área es igual
a el área de la región original o sea el
área de esta elipse que es a a por el
valor absoluto del determinante de la
matriz b de esta matriz que define a la
transformación t
y bueno tal vez parezca un salto
demasiado grande eso de pasar de
rectángulos a formas curvas como esta
pero en realidad no lo es tanto o sea
porque estas formas curvas las podemos
ver como una unión de rectángulos o sea
tenemos aquí en nuestra elipse y podemos
llenarla aquí de rectángulos o sea
podemos hacer una cuadrícula
esta figura de rectángulos por adentro y
en las orillas donde se ve que como que
no caben rectángulos de este tamaño
aquí lo que podemos hacer es poner
muchos rectángulos cada vez más
chiquitos y entonces van llenando el
área que hay aquí tenemos otro
rectángulo y bueno el chiste es que
todos estos rectángulos a la hora de que
apliquemos la transformación
si nos fijamos en la imagen de cada uno
de estos rectángulos lo que vamos a ver
son paralelo gramos ok no sé exactamente
cómo se van a ver y bueno va a estar
lleno de paralelogramo un paralelogramo
por cada rectángulo de aquí ok me está
saliendo horrible pero me muevo
el chiste es que está lleno de
paralelogramo y además cada uno de estos
rectángulos va a dar a un paralelogramo
por acá y pues ya vimos que el área de
la imagen de cada uno de estos
rectángulos es igual al área original
del rectángulo por el determinante de la
matriz b entonces si nosotros podemos
escribir el área de esta elipse como la
suma de las áreas de estos rectángulos a
la hora de pasar del otro lado cuando
aplicamos la transformación a todos
estos puntos de r2 entonces la imagen de
la elipse está compuesta por todos estos
paralelogramo y entonces su área la
podemos ver como la suma de las áreas de
estos paralelo gramos pero el área de
cada uno de estos paralelo gramos es
igual al área del rectángulo del que
proviene por el determinante de b
entonces a la hora de sumar todas estas
áreas nos va a quedar el
original de la elipse por el
determinante bebé y está muy bonito no
es otra forma de ver al determinante de
una matriz es el factor de escala de la
transformación lineal que define su
matriz ok si tenemos una región muy
chiquita y le aplicamos una
transformación definida por una matriz
cuyo determinante es muy grande entonces
esta región pequeña bajo la
transformación va a ir a dar a un
conjunto mucho más grande